and we thought how we can migrate this
low-tech industry and make it um
as as unique as we can and um
and create it create a high-tech
industry
we didn't know anything about it welcome
to 20-minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford
leap and birthright excel welcome to
another episode of 20 minute leaders
today
i'm joined by iran horowitz ceo of
credit
24. credit 24 is a fenta company which
aims to create a one-stop shop for the
online lending
industry the company has developed a
turnkey solution which allows fully
automated underwriting operation and
collection
alongside kyc and in sales retention
platform
the company uses a proprietary solution
which allows partnerships with various
companies
from insurance companies to retail
giants to offer loans credit lines or
pocs
payments without the need to develop
anything on their end
nor setting up a call center the company
was established in 2016 by iran horowitz
assaf loft and ziv rosbach horowitz
welcome to 20 minute leaders from
credit 24. how are you doing today i'm
doing great thank you
very much for having me you know we're
doing this over
over a you know web video i feel like
we're almost sitting in the same room
but
in these next 20 minutes i'm going to
learn all about your personal journey
into the
into the fintech space the the online
digital lending space
uh quite a journey uh you know we're
gonna go overseas to london for a bit
we're gonna come back to israel talk
about your experience and i want you to
take me back a little bit and tell me
you know your entrance to the fintech
world what is that about and a little
bit about who you are
okay so actually when uh when i started
um the online online business let's call
it like that
um we didn't start from fintech we
actually started at the beginning of
the early 2000s uh we started
with online gambling which is something
i'm
a friend of mine in the army i served in
my time which is uh i think everyone
already know it
so a friend of mine was was working with
a company in cyprus which uh which did
the online casino
uh it was called build the dealer
and we started from there he said there
is something really interesting
it's called online gambling you have to
try it
and and i started as an affiliate
over the years this business was amazing
people from the online gambling industry
they went uh they started doing
forex uh binary payday loans everything
you can
you can think about and then um
one of my partners he came back from uh
from the milwaukee
one day and he said you know i had a
friend over there
and he he suppose uh he's working
at a big company and he's supposed to
get paid
uh from the company but because he went
to the milwain
he should get the money from the from
the state
um and yeah he's gonna get paid within
uh 45 days but he told me he needs the
money now
so i had an idea let's try and lend them
money
because it's uh it's a sure thing like
uh i'm sure
i'm gonna get the money yeah yeah uh
no no issues are gonna happen with um
with the state of israel paying you uh
uh your uh your salary uh and that was
the idea
and then we started investigating
uh this uh this um it wasn't even
fintech it wasn't even
online lending it just uh landing and we
thought how we can
migrate this low-tech industry
and make it um as as
unique as we can and and create it
create a high-tech industry we didn't
know anything about it
uh we didn't know that there is uh
fintech and online lending companies uh
in other places in the world uh but um
but this is what we do our our whole
life so we said
let's try it um amazing and then within
uh we were sitting at ziv's apartment
which is uh the
the third partner and we were sitting in
his room
um it was a six meters uh room
i think i even wrote something about it
um
and we said let's try and do something
with it so we opened the website
and um and we created uh we created uh
something really simple and within 10
days
uh and a little bit of uh ppc
we we sold a few hundred thousand
shekels
and each loan five thousand shekels six
thousand seven thousand that
that pretty much was the the business we
said okay now let's stop
and think what we're going to do with it
because obviously we have a business
we have a saying here between the three
of us saying um
one is luck and two is a business uh we
started
when we did online gambling we said if
we can if we get one player
it's luck but if two players are um
registering and depositing money
so we are right our business so we said
okay we definitely have a business now
let's see what we can do with it
so we stopped everything and we started
building
um something from scratch we didn't know
anything about it the the landing
industry here
is pretty much was pretty much banks and
um let's call it the mafia i think it's
uh it's the best word to describe it
and the three of us was something
unfamiliar
within within this view
and then when we started uh
investigating the business and see how
it goes we
it was fascinating because we saw that
no one is doing anything online
everything is done manually and we have
to do
we had so many ideas we had
we wanted to start working but we had
nothing
we had a little bit of capital which we
wanted to invest
at the beginning but we had to start
developing everything around it and
that's pretty much how
how it started
and from there we have a lot of stories
so so now we're getting to the juicy
parts i'm just going to let you continue
because i'm just enjoying hearing this
story
um okay so so we started um so we
started uh building
a system from scratch and uh we thought
okay what
what we need to do with it and then we
saw that the um
the underwriting process is done
manually
like what you do is you get um the
person's id number
then you go and check it in on public
records and you're getting his bank
statements and his paper slip
and you want to see what he's doing and
how he's acting and the entire process
can can take a lot of time uh
so we we learned how to do this process
manually
uh over a lot of people and then we
start building the technology to do
everything automatically
now israel is lacking
i think every possible technology
technological solution you can think
about
so there's no api uh there's no way to
automate
most of the things so we had to start
developing
uh bots which can
which can act as a human so um
so we build a bot that takes the id and
goes to um
public records and takes out all the
information
uh manually you download html then you
have to pause it and then you have to
and then you have to see what what it
says and then you have to start
analyzing it
and putting it into a database and um
and then you have the bank account so
how can you
how can you automate it because
everything is manual via
papers no one even no one is even taking
pictures or sending a pdf
um so we started developing this uh the
technology
around it uh which and
the focus was was with the underwriting
because that
that was the first thing we saw um
so we started uh credit 24 um
at the beginning at the end sorry of uh
uh after a long journey in the uk
uh which i will tell you about and um
then we focused the first two years we
focused
on doing underwriting as uh as uh
as much as we can like uh everything we
can do everything we had to do manually
our competitors have to do manually we
thought how we can do it um
online and right
um we said the banks have all this
information so
so they have so much advantage how we
can
how we can get this advantage and use it
the same way how can we take the
information the bank has
and and analyze the same thing and get
uh
we think a better uh conclusion
uh so the first two years we we invested
a lot in building
the underwriting model um and gathering
as much information as we can
and we always thought that every loan
that someone takes like even
let's start from the beginning when
someone asks for a loan
uh so he either gets it or he doesn't
at that point right uh the company he
contacted
uh they forget about him like he's um if
he didn't get the loan
or he wasn't interested then he's um
dead from uh from a company point of uh
point of view we thought that
actually and we got it from the online
gambling industry
no one is dead like you can register and
then you can deposit
three years interesting so let's do the
same thing but with financing
let's take the lead let's take the
person
and continue tracking everything he does
everything we can see on an ongoing
basis
because today he's not interested or
today he's not
qualified for a loan but things can
change over time
and we don't want to lose it because we
already paid uh
for uh for this uh specific lead um
right
and the more information we gather the
better the conclusion we have
um so we took um so we took the the
whole concept of
sales and retention from from the online
gaming industry
and we implemented it with uh with the
financial
world um and then we saw that well
we're getting information and then
suddenly
someone we we said he's qualified for a
loan
but he didn't get a loan uh six months
later nine
twelve months later he was he went into
bankruptcy
so we took the we marked it we checked
the
the bankruptcy uh checkbox
and then we started analyzing manually
if we at this specific at the specific
time he registered if
if we could uh forecast the bankruptcy
what were the
the signs if there were any signs of
this person going into this thing um
and then we we started building a model
saying let's take all the information we
have
and and put it and
put all those people in in the same
place and see who went to bankruptcy who
didn't
um then try to
make a decision when the user registers
based on that information um
right yeah we saw that there are a lot
of
um a lot of value a lot of
data points um we can see
and if this specific
uh data point uh with uh a different
data point
uh altogether then the chances of going
into a bankruptcy
is uh let's say 12 and
if none of this happens the probability
of default
is going down drastically and then we
start
building those those models and saying
okay
how much pt uh the the probability of
default what is the probability of
default we wanna
we wanna have in our company so we saw
that the numbers of
um uh are uh pretty high when
going into uh non-banking solutions
because the interest rates are high um
but we wanted to build a model which
uh later on banks or big companies will
see and say okay this is what we want to
have
um right we set a mark at about two
percent uh default rate
then we started analyzing all the data
who is going
above it and who is going below it and
what are the connections between
between all those people um this is the
way the the first model
started so and obviously the more
information you have the more users you
have
uh the better the the the quality of the
underwriting is is much much better
right
so this is how it started like we came
from uh from a different point of view
uh yeah and we came from a completely
different world
the online gaming industry and we said
those
those industries the the online gaming
industry
has so much uh they know they know fraud
they know retention they know sales they
are the best and this is what we did for
more than
for more than uh uh 10 or 12 years
so so let's try and take all those
things and do
and implement in the in a new uh
in a new new world for us um
very very cool yeah so so we took a lot
of things
uh things people cannot understand
even if we tell them give them those
examples now
and they still ask us how do you know
that based on those six questions you
ask how do you know that this person
is dangerous so we give them an example
and we tell them look with uh because he
registered with this
phone number i will show you what
happened
to 20 000 or 10 000 people who
registered with this number
what is the default rate and you can see
it's going much much higher than what we
thought
so i know we're gonna have a false
positive
but when you're working on big numbers
and especially on online lending which
you have more people wanting money than
money you can
you can give then then we are okay with
the
with this decision um
this is pretty much how the this uh they
started
two years i think about two years after
we started
we we figured out okay now we have this
underwriting process we can which we can
always
improve we always add things the system
is
uh it's a it's an ai system so it learns
a lot of things
automatically
but obviously this is not it
okay so we are doing underwriting but
everywhere we go people say
we do underwriting pretty well uh we're
a bank we're
a big company so we know how to do
underwriting so we said okay we
we know we're doing things better than
most people
but i'm well sure it's not it so what we
found out was actually something we took
from
someone uh who's doing uh he has a
company he had a company he sold it for
a buck or two
um a forex company and
when when he did it because i know him
from the beginning
he always said uh those companies
they have hundreds of employees i want
to do the same thing
and have only a few dozen employees
how can i do it and he figured out
that most of the operational things
are very time consuming and you need a
lot of
human resources to deal with it so we
said
okay if it worked if it works for the
online gaming industry
and forex is pretty much part of it so
it
must be the same here so we we looked at
the company they are called mimoniasio
and we saw they had hundreds of
employees and
and they are dealing with people moving
from a job
one job to another you have to train
them you have to do a lot of things they
have mistakes they don't work 24
7. right we said okay how do we take
this whole
whole operational process and now we
make this
automatic as much as possible so
we we learned what we have to do
manually and we
started wrapping it with technology so
now pretty much
just just to understand the numbers um
kardi 24 has
six employees including the three of us
and we are dealing with hundreds of
loan requests on a daily basis so
and when you visit our office you won't
hear the phone ringing
you won't hear a lot of noise you won't
see a call center
and this is something you will see when
you're going to uh any other company
so what we did without it um
building automatic process to everything
like the first thing you see in a
lending company
is a call center we see a lot of people
sitting on the phone
uh calling people answering calls
and then okay how can i make this
automatic so we created an ivr system
which does pretty much the whole process
automatically so you call
you call the number and no
no one is answering just a and a system
is answering
it's taking it takes your phone
automatically because there's no point
of asking for it
you just put your id and the
entire process is starting from there
then the system does
follow up so no one has to call you and
say okay how much you want what do you
want to do
and the underwriting process starts
already on the phone so if if the user
asking for
a loan is not qualified based on
the underwriting process there's no use
there's no point of someone calling him
it's just a waste of time
and we saw that let's say 50 60
of loan requests are being rejected so
just imagine going
uh scaling it up to the big numbers how
much time you're spending
on call centers speaking to people who
are not relevant
now those people are registering and
they are not relevant
for either they have problems with the
banks
they don't work at the moment they are
too young whatever
but those things are changing so
we collect all this information we see
the reason that this person was rejected
and then we're just taking um
well um like pinging this user
every once in a while based on the
reason he was rejected
and then we see if something changed if
something changed and now
he's relevant for a loan he can qualify
for a loan
so the system changes his status and
then
sending him a message we're happy to say
that you are qualified
so now you can see a user registered at
but his first loan with us is 2021
but we didn't lose him he's not going
anywhere
um from that point we just moved to
everything we can think about
from uh collection automatic retention
automatic whatever and we're just
wrapping everything we can with
with technology and uh that's pretty
much
how the system works amazing and it so
it sounds like
you know you're really looking at an
industry here that is really age-old and
you're taking
you know something that is very very
regulatory very manual
and then what i'm hearing in the story
in the theme is you're constantly
figuring out which aspects of it you can
draw on
from the new world from the high tech
and from from new technologies and
implement
to change the the even the you know
psychological thinking of how this
industry operates
and how this product is being done and i
think that you've given a few examples
of how that's
of how that happens uh and and you know
there are so many things that we didn't
get to even talk about yet which is you
know you're you're starting in london
and then
and then coming to israel and with all
the different regulations and the
conflicts and and
how you're perceiving the the fintech
industry
from from that perspective inside and
out and where what's happening with
credit 24
uh today but but 20 minutes go by very
very fast so i'm gonna have to ask you
already to come to another episode
and share the second the second part of
the story
but i do have a few questions for you
again and i wanna and i
you know i wanna ask to get to know you
a little bit better so i want you to
take me back to your childhood and share
with me a little bit about your passions
and and
i i imagine you didn't grow up you know
a fintech lover
and so tell me you know what what was
what fascinated you as a kid
well two things uh space and computers
um the funny story is that um my parents
took my uh my computer
when i was a kid and they said nothing
good will grow from uh from this
and they gave me a punishment by taking
it because my
uh well i wasn't doing that well in
school
um and this is something that i remember
and i
keep telling my parents you remember you
took my computer
um but you see something obviously came
out of it
so yeah that was my passion from the
beginning
um everything thinking outside of the
box was pretty much it
um and i think space and computers
combining together
you can figure out it's it's not uh
something um
regular like um it's always thinking
about
things like like an astronaut like um
that's what how my parents called me
so this is amazing and so if if
you look through your journey was there
a figure that served as some sort of
inspiration
or some sort of role model as you go
through your journey
i think it's it's still now that um
almost
everything i do i i speak with my father
uh which i who i appreciate a lot
and it's very important for me to hear
is his point of view
and um if i need to think about someone
who
supported me uh through my entire
process
um uh definitely my father
no one i won't say any famous people you
know about
no one like that uh i i appreciate a lot
of them respect a lot of them
but the person who uh who had the most
influence was definitely my father
amazing and what are three words that
you would use to describe yourself
uh wow um
dreamer i think um because i
i vision a lot of things um
yeah well i think it's very hard to
describe uh three words it's the hardest
this is the first word uh i could think
about
um i don't know
it's hard i'm sure everyone say the same
thing
i'm very passionate and um
very i have a lot of patience
this is what some of everyone i was
saying
patience is that's very unique i don't
think i've heard that one yet
the patience yeah so this is definitely
patience is definitely one of those
things
wonderful thank you very very much i
really appreciate
it and and i look forward to sharing the
story and i look forward to hearing the
second part of the story
but until then stay safe and stay
healthy thank you
thank you see you soon thank you very
much thank you
[Music]